hyrule warriors age of calamity has
recently been announced and in the short
video nintendo has shown off there are
some interesting pieces of info that
left us with many answers but also more
questions that got us theorizing
here are some details that you might
have missed
link is now seen here confirmed canon in
the soldier's outfit
it's hard to say exactly when and why
link switches armor and equipment
because link has never been seen outside
his champion's tunic outfit before his
100 year slumber
the most likely scenario is that some
battles that take place in age of
calamity took place before his knighting
as champion and before the appearance of
calamity ganon
it is pointed out in one cut scene that
there were major battles fought with
dangerous foes before the great calamity
next let's talk about the gameplay
element of this battle scene for a
couple frames there's already a
previously exploding bomb
in the background suggesting that there
is a return of both links remote bombs
or at least multiple bombs
as he hurls the second one the actual
bomb itself has a hitbox knocking
bokoblins away
when it explodes an enemy platform gets
destroyed but it's not actually known if
it holds enemies like it did in breath
of the wild
as for the logistics of this how does
link have access to remote bombs it is
required to have the sheikah slate to
use runes such as bombs and stasis and
during this time in the past
zelda clearly has a sheikah slate at
this point there's no clear answer but
hopefully we'll get our answers soon
at least it's confirmed that shield
surfing is back and it looks insanely
fun
on the same train of thought zelda is
seen using the sheikah slate to great
effect here
and her animation suggests that this
attack might be an area of effect stasis
an attack that freezes all enemies in
its radius which is pretty neat
zelda is also seen here using magnesius
and bomb runes herself with arguably
greater effect than link himself
we get our first glimpse at who is most
likely impa in the throne room
impa is actually seen twice in this
trailer once in the throne room and once
outside the malus infested hyrule castle
we will probably get to see her side of
the story assisting link and zelda in
the fight against ganon
there are also tiny clues to elemental
imbued weapons as well in certain combat
scenes
erbozo's rocking her signature scimitar
of the seven that is electrified
naturally during combat
and rivali is possibly using some sort
of gale arrows this could just be crazy
enemy knockback due to the nature of
most musou games but the way the enemies
fly in the air and the wind effects
circling the arrows suggest otherwise
there's been speculation that gale
arrows were scrapped idea for breath of
the wild so this is not completely
impossible
towards the end of the trailer link is
finally seen with the signature
champions tunic and master sword
he's seen sword clashing with some sort
of thunder type weapon but on closer
inspection the tip of the blade is
nothing like any current electric breath
of the wild weapon
and as we suspected that is definitely
the highland shield that link has
equipped which has never canonically
been shown in any cut scene as something
link would use in breath of the wild
until now maybe we'll finally see how he
got it and how it ended up in the
basement of hyrule castle
finally we got a tease of what's
possibly an entirely new enemy or friend
in the front cover box art this mini
guardian remains a mystery for now but
is most probably extremely important as
its front and center of the champions
hyrule warriors age of calamity is set
to release november 20th
with more details coming ahead of its
release in september 26th this will more
than likely have more gameplay details
and story as to keep a tight lip on the
plot
even though we all know how it ends for
all things breath of the wild we'll keep
you informed with in-depth
content so stay tuned right here on
[Music]
gamespot
you